[Music]
[Music]
I'm Jeremy Brock welcome to the BAFTA
and BFI international screenwriters
lecture series for 2013 I was on the
BAFTA Film committee and discovered I
was the only screenwriter who'd ever
been on it and after I got over the
shock I decided that the best I could do
for my screenwriting brothers and
sisters was to set up a lecture series
in the name of BAFTA and we were able to
bring the BFI in on that this year we've
got a fantastic lineup we start with
David s Goyer we end with Richard Curtis
and in between we have Hossein Amini
Susannah grant and Tony Gilroy these are
serious heavyweights from the UK and
from America you will be inspired by
these individuals so to kick off 2013
we've got David s Goyer opening the
lecture series if you look at his body
of work it's someone who has huge
cultural significance and yet - most
people he'll be an invisible name I was
first aware of David's work through
Batman and if you think about the reach
of David's blockbusters they aren't
bound to have an impact culturally and
they're bound to have an impact on
screenwriting a lot of very very serious
heavyweight screenwriters are now moving
to television and David is one of those
so if he can speak to that particular
shift and bias that would be brilliant
it's a huge honor for us to be able to
bring David into the series and we look
forward to him speaking I'm 47 years old
I sold my first screenplay when I was 21
it wasn't a very good script and the
resulting film wasn't much to brag about
but it got me my start
I landed an agent when I was 20 and
here's how I'd read about a young man
that had become an agent when he was 22
and I reasoned that someone who had made
agent at the age of 22 was probably a
hustler and I wanted that kind of person
working for me
so I cold called his office from my
dormitory room I was still in school at
the time and I left a message with his
secretary saying that I'd written a
screenplay and his assistant promised to
get back to me and I knew she never
would I hung hung up and I said thank
you so the next day I called his office
again and I left the same message the
third day I called his office again and
left the same message I kept doing that
for 45 business days this is true
finally on the 45th business day the
agent jumped on the line and he barked
into the phone who the [ __ ] are you and
why do you keep calling me and I knew I
had a couple of seconds and I said my
name is David s Goyer and I've written a
screenplay and even at 20 I added yes
because I thought it lent some kind of
mystique or something like that and I
said I'm about to graduate from film
school and I've written this amazing
screen plan I'm going to be a really big
writer someday and if you don't sign me
you're going to regret it and he laughed
and he said [ __ ] it send me your script
but don't call me every day to see if
I've read it or not so I sent my script
in and I waited two weeks and then I
started calling him every day
Bannen Oh for two or three weeks finally
he picked up the phone again and he said
your scripts actually pretty good so he
he's he was going to sign me and then he
admitted that he decided he was going to
sign me even if my script was mediocre
and I said why in the world would you do
that and he said because I'd shown such
ridiculous confidence in calling him
every day that he figured I'd probably
get somewhere now why did I show such
confidence and there's a point to this I
didn't really have anything to lose I
was sitting in my dorm room literally in
my underwear calling every day and I
just thought what's the worst thing that
can happen the guy would laugh at me and
he'd hang up and or maybe tell me I was
a shitty writer and at the beginning of
my career I had a number of people tell
me that I was a shitty writer so here's
my first point probably every successful
writer and stage screening of prose has
been told some version of give up at
some point in their career it's
rejection and if you can't deal with it
if you can't pick yourself up off the
floor after someone has completely
crushed your soul if you can't continue
onward then you probably shouldn't be
trying to write for a living so that's
why sort of first pearl of wisdom the
other thing now I'm going off book for a
second when you're trying to write for
screen this is film or television as you
think you know you're trying to convince
someone to make your script and I think
what a lot of beginning writers or even
professional writers don't realize and I
had this epiphany about five years into
my career you're not just getting your
film made you're killing off those other
999 scripts the possibility in order to
even get a small film made someone else
has to spend a million dollars or two
million dollars for three million
dollars or three hundred million dollars
so part of writing a good script is
actually convincing people to risk all
their money in their livelihoods in
making your film anyway thanks to my
perseverance I got an agent but I hadn't
yet sold a script my agent asked me if I
could try my hand at writing
action film I never thought it would be
in action writer I thought I would write
comedies I probably glad I didn't do
that but uh diehard had just come out
and a few minutes later I wrote a script
called dusted it was a story about a cop
who gets sent in to prison undercover
and at the time I was working at a
runner at a studio as a runner and I was
delivering mail and getting executive
bagels gruntwork my agent called me in
the middle of a bagel run literally and
he said there's this guy named
jean-claude Van Damme do you know who he
is I didn't he calls himself JC anyway
he'd made a moderate splash with a
couple of B movies called bloodsport and
kickboxer and he'd read my script and he
wanted to meet a few years later a few
hours later I was sitting down with him
JC was this sort of Belgian pretty boy
model who'd learned how to do the splits
and a spinning wheel kick and somehow
got himself like a film deal he could
barely speak English but he was very
enthusiastic an MGM was going to make a
new film with him and JC said and I'll
always remember this he said I think
you're a great writer said Hollywood
will try to destroy you
this is verbatim but I will protect you
like an eagle and he made that motion
and then he gave me a big hug and this
is true and he kind of you know rubbed
his knuckles on top of my head like you
would with your little brother and then
completely randomly he said the
homosexuals love me
all true ah and I remember thinking
should I ask him what that means I was
like now I'm not gonna ask him that
means anyway he said he wanted to have
MGM buy my script and he wanted to start
production on it immediately incredibly
that's exactly what happened four months
later I was on the set of my first film
I was 22 at the time I had to take all
of Jacey's dialogue and sort of portion
it out to other actors because he could
barely speak English um and I had to
change the title to death warrant
because MGM had market research titles
and death had scored well so dusted
became death warrant and I thought you
know I could show clips of like really
good stuff that I've done and I guess
I'll do that but I'm going to show a
clip of death warrant
[Music]
[Music]
but we all have to start somewhere
and you know which leads me my to my
second sort of pearl of wisdom which is
everyone wants to write an Academy
award-winning film or a BAFTA when you
film their first time out but there's
nothing wrong from learning your craft
in the trenches Coppola and Scorsese
started out with Roger Corman Jonathan
Demi James Cameron in those days B
movies were a good place to kind of earn
your water wings I never worked with
Corman but I worked with Van Damme and
and believe it or not he actually taught
me some things
he once said to me and this is true
while we were filming that movie he said
one day you'll write a script it's too
good for me and thankfully I did in 1994
I wrote a script called blade and that
script changed my career completely the
first time I wrote a script without any
editorial interference an indicative a
new line a Michael De Luca he gave it a
shot and he didn't try to dictate the
story he just said write it the way you
think it should be written and this is a
very rare thing to happen and there's
another pearl wisdom hidden there hire
someone you think is talented and they
get the [ __ ] out of the way that script
it wasn't made immediately it flowed
around for about four years before it
went into production but it was a script
that the community liked it was passed
around from one film executive to
another and they liked it because it was
brash because it didn't feel like a
generic Hollywood film the reason it
didn't feel generic is because I was
writing what I wanted to write and I
didn't have any regard for what
Hollywood might desire and even though
the script took a while to get made I
was now being offered projects as
opposed to having to audition for them
so my point here is that a good script
can open doorways for you even if it
never makes it into production I've been
involved in three film franchises now
where I was allowed to write with
virtually no creative interference the
Blade films The Dark Knight trilogy Man
of Steel and it hasn't been lost on me
that those three projects were also
ones that were the most financially
successful and he can't just chalk it up
to the fact that batman/superman are
well-known because nobody knew who blade
was and around the time I wrote blade I
had a set of business cards printed up
and I was feeling kind of bullish and
they just said David s Goyer writer and
I showed them to my writing mentor and
he promptly took the card and he threw
it in the trash and he said no writer
worth his salt principle [ __ ]
business card that says writer on it
you're not a writer you're a human being
who writes for a living so here comes I
guess another pearl of wisdom
Nelson was old school he considered
writing a craft as opposed to an art he
felt that all writing even science
fiction or fantasy needed to be based on
human experience one of his gripes with
young writers like myself is that we
wanted to start writing films without
actually living any of our lives so I
threw away my business cards and I
started traveling I went to the South
Pacific I learned to scuba dive I bought
a motorcycle I crashed a motorcycle I
went skydiving I went to Africa and
South America all throughout Asia I got
out of my comfort zone and I got some
life experience in my travels I'd
managed to go trekking in Tibet and when
Chris Noland I sat down to reinvent
Batman we wanted Bruce Wayne to travel
far afield and I showed Chris some of my
photographs from Tibet which I had taken
during my experience and those formed
the basis for Bruce Wayne's Vision Quest
you can show a couple he's down but the
point is I never would have imagined
that that trip would have become the
basis for the beginning of that and
begins and it did now I'm going to
completely crush all of your dreams
while the screen writing industry has
contracted the televised television
writing industry has expanded television
is no longer regarded as a second-tier
medium instead of having to tell your
story in two hours you've got six
episodes or 13 characters and audiences
are given the opportunity to grow
writers also tend to be better treated
in television it's true film is the
directors medium in the television at
least at least in America the writers
came and there's a reason for that in
television directors tend to be more
itinerant and serialized television
writers can't be someone needs to keep
track of the story lines is that line of
dialogue consistent with Lady Mary
Crowley's backstory
who are we going to ask we can ask the
director or we can ask Julian Fellowes
we're probably gonna ask Julian Fellowes
who's going to keep track of Don
Draper's myriad lies probably Matthew
Weiner the guy who invented them in the
American system we have a class of
writers known as show runners Brett
Martin recently published a book on the
subject entitled difficult men behind
the scenes of create of a creative
revolution from The Sopranos and the
wire to madmen and Breaking Bad if you
haven't read it it's an interesting book
and the premise is basically simple you
get good television when creators refuse
to compromise on their creative visions
which takes me back to the lesson of
hiring talented people and getting the
[ __ ] out of the way interestingly enough
it's a critical perception of television
has risen we've seen this reverse
migration back into features and
amusingly the justification used by film
executives when hiring TV writers now is
that they're looking for writers who are
capable of more character nuance and
narrative complexity in other words all
the kinds of things that used to make
movies good are now tend to be having on
television but if an infusion of TV
writers can make film more watchable I'm
all for it
so where does that leave writers well
they're always going to be a certain
number of temple pictures made every
year and I suspect we're going to be
stuck with spandex and dystopian teen
melodramas for a long time but Jerry
Bruckheimer I think was essentially
right television one conventional
Widow's wisdom taught us that all these
new distribution platforms like internet
streaming and video video on-demand if
they would cannibalize the television
industry but in actuality they haven't
the numbers bear it out - people are
simply watching more television on
smartphones and tablets on the backs of
seats and airplanes and the industry as
a whole particularly the international
market is booming increasingly the big
conglomerates are divesting themselves
of any branch that is in pure media
warner brothers is dumped a while
AOL and Time fox's spinning off news and
book publishing there's even talk about
sheddy
a Sony shedding its consumer products
division why because over the last
decade the core media businesses have
been the one that have been the most
profitable in the last four years Time
Warner's stock is nearly tripled same
with Viacom Fox and Disney and all of
that growth has been driven by the newly
umber
television industry which is much more
profitable than the film industry which
is in turn being built on the backs of
writers writers are increasingly
crafting stories that are challenging
and genre busting and they're creating
the kinds of memorable roles that keep
people up at night chattering away on
Twitter and the message board so is the
sky falling not really it's just that
the work and the opportunities are
migrating elsewhere believe it or not I
think today is a more exciting time to
be entering into the film industry than
when I started back in 88 it's just that
now in which the exciting stuff is
actually happening on the small screen
as opposed to inside the multiplexes so
all the pearls of wisdom my iterated
tonight still apply in television and
maybe some of you will be lucky and will
write some films but certainly the work
is migrating their perseverance life
experience right you feel passionate
about not what you think the market is
dictating at the end of the day good
writing and passionate writing I do
believe will always win out and if you
have a card that says blankety-blank
writer consider throwing it out you
mentioned blade earlier and that was the
kind of script that started you on this
path that you're on and it also set this
of a template for kind of modern comic
book movies why do you think it changed
things I mean it was pre x-men it was
pre The Matrix I mean it was kind of it
changed action movies is what a comic
book movies but why was that I think
there were three sort of reasons um one
is is nobody was making action films in
particular that had you know
african-american leads new line had made
I think deep cover and house-party did
sort of they were this kind of like
scruffy little kind of mini studio that
were making films that the other Studios
wouldn't make and at the time they said
we will make this script if you can
write it in the six to eight million
dollar range and and the budget for my
first draft came in at forty five
million dollars
and incredibly the same guy Michael De
Luca who had said just write what you
want to write and he literally gave me
no notes he he just said bucket let's
make it and it was r-rated and and his
immediate bosses said you are insane you
know there's no marketable black star
and it's r-rated and it's going to
completely fail and and it was this
crazy sort of mash up of blaxploitation
and I was at the people are very into
Hong Kong action films at the time but
people weren't into it back then but I
was I would see these film festivals I
think it just worked because it kind of
broke the rules of what an action film
should be it was just completely gonzo
and the other thing that was interesting
is steady if there was a convention that
in Hollywood that you could only make a
comic book film if it was based on the
sort of top to your characters Batman
Superman maybe spider-man x-men hadn't
even been made and there was no thought
that you could make a film out of a
secondary or tertiary character and at
the time this is true Marvel thought so
little of this character that they
optioned it to new line for a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars that
was all Marvel made on that film and on
the second film I think they made like
175 thousand and finally I think knew
lying waste took well no no they had
they had them over a barrel but the
movies went on to make collectively over
a billion dollars and it was a big
eye-opener for Marvel they realized that
that they didn't just have to be
well-known characters if there was
something interesting in the DNA that
they could still become these big giant
brands and you think it's because you
took the characters seriously yes he's
put them in the real world I thank you
for saying that yeah that was the other
thing that I did is I just said I'm I'm
not going to write it like it's a joke
it's not a week and a nod I'm going to
pretend it's real which is what we ended
up doing Chris and I with Batman Begins
the Burton films which I love but
they're very cartoony in their own way
and we just said our main working rule
was we're just going to pretend as if
it's real and it made it more difficult
in the writing process also because
that also meant it that everything he
did had at least have some basis in
reality and we couldn't just do it
because that it was cool or that was you
know that was the way it happened in the
comic books and I think that resonated
with people and you mentioned confidence
earlier and you said that that was the
script that you suddenly felt that you
you were a screenwriter um how many
scripts down the line had you me I think
at that point I had it was probably the
tenth screenplay I had written in it it
wasn't until blade you're right that I
felt like I I actually deserve to have
anything made out of my films but I'd
had four or five bad things made prior
to that nobody knew blade at all and I
did a lot of invention
so with blade but there was something
that was similar to blade in terms of
Man of Steel and and Batman I would try
to distill what was the DNA of the
character and in the case of Batman or
Superman you know I had read a lot of
the material but I went back and
reimbursed myself and a lot of the
material and I developed this process
where I would just I would write down
themes and elements of the story or
origin story that were sticky so in the
case of Batman and Superman you've got
these characters have been around for
seventy years that are constantly being
reinvented and they're changing the
origin stories and they're changing how
they meet the Joker or how they meet you
know character X Y and C but over the
decades certain elements remain sticky
they kind of it's sort of like story
story Darwinism they would bubble to the
surface and you would say and I
identified about ten things that remain
sticky about that man and ten things
that remain sticky about Superman and I
wrote him up and I said to Chris these
are the 10 things that must be in the
movie that we heard that we should not
change and I did the same thing that was
a con Superman and I said they were sort
of like the 10 commandments and and I
decided as long as we stick to that I
think we'll be good as long as we honor
that you said that reinventing Superman
was even honed
and Batman and you he's just not as
innately cool as Batman I mean DC give
you kind of free license to do anything
that you want to because I mean I
remember talking to grant morrison years
ago on and he about this aborted
Superman pitch yeah I wanted Superman to
kind of push the moon yeah and they said
to him he can't be that super they
didn't well blade had been successful
and I think on some level they had
figured like if he can do something okay
out of blade baby he could figure
something out but but the one thing that
Kris and I did that none of the other
filmmakers prior to us had done we we
went to New York and we met with the
publisher and the main editors of Batman
on our own dime we met with him for two
days and before we even started we said
what do you think should be in a Batman
film and are there any rules that you
would absolutely not break and and I
mean it sounds simple but none of the
other filmmakers had bothered to do that
they just dismissed sort of the comic
books and the creators and I just
thought these guys have been doing it
for you know six decades they know
something and and and we learned a lot
of things so I think that they we earned
their trust and then when it came to
Superman and they said you've got it
they just didn't go and I've written
comic books as well where I disagree
with some of my comic book writers
there's that Superman doesn't kill but
it's a it's a it's a rule that exists
outside of the narrative and I just
don't believe in rules like that
I believe when you're writing a film or
television you can't rely on a crutch or
a rule that exists outside of the
narrative of the film and so the
situation was Saad has said I'm not
going to stop until you kill me or I
kill you and the reality is no prison on
the planet could hold him and in our
film Superman can't fly to the moon and
and we didn't want to come up with that
crotch and so we wanted him to kill but
it also our movie was in a way Superman
begins he's not really Superman until
the film and we wanted him to have that
experience of of having taken a life and
then to carry that through hopefully on
to the next films having been backed
into that corner and realized that
because he's Superman because people
idolize him he needs to hold himself to
a higher standard before I throw open to
you I'm going to ask you a couple of
quick surprise you know in addition to
writing baton to the ballot for whatever
it's called Man of Steel to your
executive using da Vinci's demons you
write videogames you're producing
several movies several TV shows um how
do you do it I mean what I just just
explained your kind of process do you
work where do you work for instance do
you write longhand I mean just because
it just seems like a phenomenal amount
of work for one individual did you sleep
I mean I sleep yeah I well when I
started out in fact it I've been writing
professionally I don't know for 26 years
something like that and and when I
started out I could only write one thing
and I've gotten faster it's like any
muscle and and I and I've gotten to a
place where I can multitask when you say
you motor to us can you write two or
three scripts at the same time well you
have to finish one now I write two or
three scripts at the same time or not
and I will block out the day I mean it's
ridiculous but it'll seem you'll see my
calendar and I'll say like Man of Steel
from 9:30 to 11:30 in the Vinci's demons
from 11:30 to 1 and this other project
from 1 to 2 and and I do and that's what
I do and you mentioned being a director
has has that impacted your writing I
think it's made me a better writer
because there's a lot of cheats that you
can do as a writer and you know I
remember I referenced Stephen Norrington
in the first play to film in an early
draft I had described a character
walking in the room looking like a
living nightmare and Steve said what
what
like what how do i what does that mean
and I realize no person you would read
the script up to that point hey question
I realize yeah you're right it doesn't
mean anything
I mean it's it's it's cool but it
doesn't really mean anything and so I
don't I don't cheat anymore if I know
I'm writing you know for another
director okay go okay with us right open
to you question in the middle please
hello thank you for mothers talking
fantastic and I want you to ask you what
your experience was to write it in the
games world and how you see that artform
evolving I'm a gamer and I do consider
it an art form the game industry is
still kind of in its fledgling days but
I do think the narratives are becoming
more complex and I think the game
industry is realizing that they have to
be technology I think it's been driving
the narrative in games because as as the
CG and motion capture made it look more
realistic it put more of an onus I think
on the game makers to make the dialogue
that they're saying feel more realistic
because suddenly they aren't just you
know 8-bit pixel characters uttering
things it doesn't kind of matter what
they say when they're 8 bits to a
certain extent but if they look almost
photo-real it matters and more and more
the game industry is sort of realizing
that and you said it's more like writing
television the movies yeah writing
writing for games is more like writing
television because if each level is sort
of like an episode and kind of adds a
beginning middle and end and then if you
do something like the second blackops
that I did where we have branching
narratives
it's not even linear you literally based
on the decisions you make I think we had
something like 17 or 18 different
endings so that was a really interesting
process as well we had to come up with
it it was very complicated it could sort
of flowchart of if a then B then C kind
of thing and that was fun to work on too
I mean and also interesting because I
mean that first game came out and did
more money than avatar and so it was
kind of incredible to work on something
like that and then the second one did
again it was bigger than the Dark Knight
or Man of Steel will ever be yeah I mean
grandma's also made 800 million yes
first day yeah it's just astonishing
there's one there somewhere there's been
a number of video games that have been
adapted for the big screen but nothing
I've ever seen to work convincingly I
was wondering if you had an opinion why
they didn't work I do I do I think
there's really only been one successful
video game adaptation and I that was
probably Tomb Raider well you know
whether or not you think it's a good
movie it was successful financially but
I think that's probably the only one
that was really financially successful
and I think the reason is is actually
pretty simple then most good video games
are about immersive environments if it's
a first-person shooter you are the
character or you're entering the world
where most video games tend well that is
changing but tend not to have strong
characters if you think about video
games you think about how cool that
level was or how amazing often gamers
will talk about oh that was so cool when
I did this or I did that and you realize
if you're adapting an environment or a
milieu into film the video game is
actually does a better job of it they
like the film will never do as good or
as immersive job as the video game once
we start seeing video games that have
more sort of memorable characters than I
think you'll see more successful video
game adaptations I mean we'll see if
Assassin's Creed works that seems like
the best candidate right now I assume
there is an evil films make money yeah
actually that is I will say that but I I
think they they get a pass because they
were doing the sort of zombie survival
horror thing I mean I don't know I mean
I like the games and I like the movies
but I don't think it's because Eve is
better is that her name it's like a
super amazing character yeah Alice Alice
this there's a guy over there
I was just wondering in your career
dance what you would think of as your
biggest challenge and leave your
proudest moment you know I'm really
proud of Batman Begins because I felt
like we changed comic book films I mean
I you know Kristin I really wanted to
make something that was reminiscent of
Lawrence of Arabia or you know things
like that
so I'm proud of that and I'm um I'm
proud of Man of Steel like it's it's
it's really hard to adapt Superman and
he hadn't been cool on film for a long
time and even though the film was
controversial interestingly enough I've
had more people come up to me to thank
me for that film than even you know the
Batman films so I'm proud of that and I
also think Man of Steel Man of Steel was
definitely the hardest script I've ever
written because I remember getting the
job by saying oh I'm going to do a first
contact story and then sitting down to
write it and and just being utterly
paralyzed for a week or two because I
just thought what the [ __ ] have I done I
wrote I wrote exterior Krypton Day in
the north
[ __ ] and that's that's where I said okay
okay and I think I wrote like exterior
Philadelphia day like and then so I'm
just going to do that first and she that
works and he's a tree you came up the
idea to do sweet men while you were
stuck on that it's true okay here's
here's a an argument for multitasking
we were we were Chris and I were working
on the story for The Dark Knight Rises
and we were just utterly blocked and he
said all right let's just part ways for
a week and see what happens and I just
went into my office and I go into my
home office even if even if I don't have
an idea I'll still make myself sit there
during those hours and just sat there
and sat there trying to figure out what
the hell to do on the Dark Knight Rises
and then I because all writers
procrastinate I started reading some
Superman comic books instead and and
then just spent two days writing
Superman ideas even though someone else
was working on a Superman movie and and
yeah I came back after a week and Chris
said so if you cracked that problem on
the dark night and I said no he said
what have you been doing today why I
have this idea for Superman and because
Chris also likes to procrastinate he
said okay what is it uh and I told him
and he was like that's that's really
cool I look at it and then this never
happens he called up the head of the
studio and said gogurts just told me an
idea for Superman I don't care what else
you're working on I want us to come in
and pitch it to you and then he hung up
the phone he said do you mind if I
produce it I was like what are you
kidding me sure it's great and then we
went in and then suddenly they weren't
doing the other movie and we were doing
this movie oh geez
one of the biggest differences is that
you have to write a beginning in middle
and end in two hours so it's incredibly
compressed with television if you're
doing serialized television it's
open-ended and you can have characters
like in Breaking Bad go from being a
protagonist to an end takis it's very
difficult to do that in film if you've
only got two hours you can have
characters grow and change you can have
characters surprise you even in the
DaVinci's demons we had a secondary
character who we had scripted and filmed
his death scene in Episode six and then
we saw the cut of Episode three in which
it just so happened that actor had had
more to do in that episode and he was
really good and we unkilled him and and
we filmed this scene in which he didn't
die and then his agent then we said okay
great you're going to be in season two
it as an agent said great we're going to
read any Goshen is to hold on we
actually have the film une which we
killed your guys character so you really
don't have us over a barrel but that
kind of stuff doesn't happen in film and
be in the other thing that happens in
television that's very different is that
there is a feedback loop between the
audience and the filmmakers I mean it's
it's a delayed response but if you're
lucky enough to be still making your
show after people have watched or
consumed the DVD I mean we're not we're
not immune to what's going on and you
listen and there's a feedback loop and
people be you know certain characters
rise to the surface that might not have
happened and that debt can't happen in
film because you make it and it's done
and it goes out to the audience and
there's no feedback loop with the
audience I'm afraid I must bring this to
an end so please put your hands together
and thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]